and I can I just ask you again how how
it felt to jump out today poetry no I do
I use really relaxed with all my
companions in the aircraft and yeah they
make it make me feel very relaxed but I
wanted to go that door and just again if
you could explain and describe what it
was like on the night of course dee dee
well we dropped very low we didn't stay
in here as long as we did today but yeah
we can lift aircraft about 500 feet what
was going through your mind the type of
aircraft were certainly nowhere near
that c-130 there but Albemarle Bombers
modified to carry policies nine of us in
each aircraft and when you hit the
ground the German enemy was away that's
a good way of who knew yeah smash into
the ground yeah rough landing
well my tailbone is no my collarbone
what were you thinking about on that
night as you were coming into occupied
France
completely I would say well was we had a
task to do and that was foremost in
their minds he just couldn't reach the
girl and sit in your backside with what
you had There was I consider well excuse
me a considerable might to be done and
we our main target was to liberate
Rhonda which we did before for slate and
what were you thinking about when you
jumped out of the plane this afternoon
what was going through your mind I was
hoping there'd be some Calvados down
here there remembering the men that you
jumped with of course it's extremely
humbling for me to be be in my own you
know my I'm shyra through the world
olders there's other guys but I was
looking around for some companionship in
the echo and happily I was the only one